Bueno realmente este crimen en contra de
María Belén Bernal es un hecho que ha
conmocionado al país Han sido días Muy
duros Han sido días muy tristes Como
algunos elementos importantes y puntos
relevantes a tener en cuenta la madre de
María Elena manifestado que irá a
instancias internacionales ella ha sido
muy enfática en decir que no descansará
hasta que se haga justicia por su hija
evidentemente todos los ciudadanos
Ecuatorianos vamos a tener una gran
responsabilidad en acompañar a Elizabeth
en esta difícil lucha creo que también
es importante mapear algunas cuestiones
que se vienen por ejemplo fiscalía
informado que la investigación que se va
a realizar estará acompañada por un
criminólogo por un fiscal y por un
experto perito de Colombia creo que esta
decisión es acertada porque en este
momento es fundamental que exista
garantías de un proceso transparente con
expertos y con objetividad también
vendrá una comisión de de Sid
has mencionado ya que el presidente ha
pedido pues la renuncia del ministro
Carrillo y también Creo que va a ser
importante tener en cuenta que por cómo
se han dado los hechos Sí o sí habrá que
ver las consecuencias que tienen los los
delitos que se dieron por omisión
también la próxima semana han sido
llamados algunos funcionarios a rendir
cuentas a la asamblea nacional y decide
precisamente según distintas
organizaciones y ya son 206 feminicidios
registrados en Ecuador en lo que va de
año porque este caso ha conmocionado de
esta forma al país y ha generado esta
fuerte reacción por parte del ejecutivo
es correcto este caso ha desatado fuerte
reacciones por diferentes razones
primero porque se trata de un delito que
más allá de afectar directamente a la
familia de María Belén pues es un caso
que ha terminado afectando a la
colectividad ecuatoriana como sociedad
creo que como sociedad quedamos muy
golpeados y Ecuador se encuentra de luto
por esta pérdida que evidencia apenas de
un pequeño fragmento de cómo estamos
como sociedad
enfrentando este este caso de y algunos
otros de violencia contra la mujer
también Creo que parte del descontento
tiene que ver con Como algunos sectores
dan tergiversado la información
intentando culpar a la víctima con
cuestionamientos de por estar de cómo
eligió a su pareja o de por ejemplo
porque tomó esa decisión entonces creo
que que eso responde también a Por qué
la reacción fuerte de la gente Pues por
eso descontento se termina culpando a la
víctima y decide precisamente no a estas
peticiones de renuncias de altos mandos
son una Clara condena pero Cuáles son
las políticas en materia de prevención
de feminicidios en Ecuador
Ecuador en el 2014 tipificó al femicidio
como como un delito no Este es un delito
que nosotros lo tenemos de nuestro
código orgánico integral sin embargo
Lamentablemente el tipificar el
femicidio fue un paso importante en la
legislación ecuatoriana no obstante la
tipificación del delito no ha tenido un
el resultado que se esperaba desde el
ámbito de mis competencias en la
dirección Nacional de Derechos Humanos
género de inclusión del Ministerio de
salud pública se trabaja mucho en el
tema de sensibilización sobre la
violencia de género Creo que este es uno
de los ideales hay que trabajar en
educación para poder realmente erradicar
la violencia de género